Podcast UFO? Podcast UFO? Podcast UFO? Oh, wow, schöner Abschluss. Herzlich willkommen zu dieser Sonnefolge Podcast. Wir müssen kurz noch warten, bis Stefan von der Tanzfläche zurückgekehrt ist. Er hat sich extra seine Schuhe angezogen. Ich habe meine Schuhe angezogen. Hi, ja, wow, das hat mich wirklich mitgerissen. Du hast es noch mal krachen gelassen.
Ich bin ganz außer Atem, ich habe den Tanzfuss geschwungen, das Tanzbein und den Tanzkörper. Alles geschwungen. Tanzarm ist zu Hause geblieben, weil die Arme immer sehr unbeweglich sind. Bisschen wie Riverdance, was ja eigentlich normales Tanzen ohne Arme einfach nur ist, habe ich mir sagen gelassen. Ne, finde ich aber auch praktisch, dass man die Körperteile einzeln tanzen lässt und dann einfach mal sagt, heute ist Abendtag, heute machen die Arme die Arbeit und die Beine nicht so. Die Beine machen, was sie wollen oder die Arme machen, was sie wollen, je nachdem. Was bist du für ein Tänzer? Sehr, auch ich bin eher fast ausschließlich Arme. Ne, du bist vor allem ausschließlich ironischer Tänzer. Doch du bist übertrieben, es gibt verschiedene Leute. Also es gibt zum einen, es fängt an, stell dich mal so ein Flussdiagramm jetzt vor, okay? So, es fängt oben an mit Tanzen gerne, ja oder nein. Wir beide sind beide eher nein, wir tanzen nicht gerne. Dieses nein teilt sich aber auf in Tanzen auf ein Minimum reduzieren. Das ist ein Baumdiagramm. Ich meine ein Baumdiagramm. Ja, okay. Was ist immer ein Flussdiagramm dann? Habe ich in meinem Leben noch nicht gehört. Fließt runter? Ja. Dachte ich gerade. Wie in der Windschutzscheibe. Und wieder sind wir bei der Geografie angekommen. Jedenfalls, okay, nennen wir das ein Baumdiagramm. Ja. Aber halt ein umgeritter Baum, wenn nach unten ästelt. Deswegen meine ich Plusdiagramm vielleicht, ist ja auch egal. Unten, geht's weiter runter, ähm, wir tanzen beide nicht gerne. Wurzeldiagramm. Ich jedenfalls, beschränk's dann auf ein Minimum, ich mach dann Füsse von rechts nach links, ne, wie ein Klassiker, den Hitch der Date-Doktor-Tanz, wo man dann noch ein bisschen schnipst vielleicht mal hier und da, Minimum-Arme, halt Beine, rechts, links, zu jedem Lied kannst du tanzen, wippst ein bisschen mit, machst ein gutes Gesicht dazu, bis im Takt, easy. Du jedenfalls bist eher der andere Extrem des Nicht-Tanzen-Wollens, du schaffst Distanz zum Tanzen durch überbordende Ironie. Ja, ich will einen grossen Eindruck machen in kurzer Zeit, um dann möglichst schnell wieder gehen zu können. Ja, ja. Damit es heißt, oh wow, der hat echt was hingelegt, wo ist er eigentlich, weg, hat einen schönen irgendwie zwanzig Mini-Bounties in die Hose und Taschen gestopft und ist abgehauen, das ist so meine perfekte Party. Hat dann aber so ein bisschen den Faden beigeschmack, dass man denkt, hat er sich übernommen beim Tanzen, weil er hat zu viel aufs Parkett gelegt, sagt man ja auch, und dann ist er weg und dann macht man sich vielleicht Gedanken. War da gerade die Feuerwehr, was ist passiert, ist er hingefallen?
Warum ist die Toilette so lange belegt, war es das Keuchen da drin, hat er sich vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben? Vorausgabt. Wer kommt da humpelnd aus der Toilette hinaus? Das sind dann die Fragen, die sich stellen über den Lauf eines solchen Abends. Aber es wird über dich gesprochen und das will man ja am Ende dieses Tages doch. Ja, ich hatte ja tatsächlich mal in meiner grossen Clubphase, sagen wir mal 2012, 11, sagen wir mal März, sagen wir mal 13. März 2012. Ja, einfach mal so. Und da war ich sogar in der Kultfabrik in München im Q-Club, der angesagteste Club der Stadt. Und da habe ich getanzt und habe in meinem Tanzrausch irgendwann bemerkt und habe hochgeschaut, dass mich drei Leute gefilmt haben mit ihren Handys. Oh, weil du bekannt warst als vorhin den Wild?
Nee, gar nicht. Elf, das ist ja, nee, aber einfach, weil sie anscheinend den Anblick eines fetten, schwitzenden, hyperaktiv tanzenden, am epileptischen Anfall kratzenden Tanzstils sehr lustig fanden. Und ich weiss nicht, was aus diesen Videos geworden ist. Eines Tages warte ich immer noch, wenn ich diese Fail-Videos angucke,
diese Fail-Compilations, dass eines
Tages mir ein vertrautes,
etwas übergewichtiges Gesicht
entgegen hechelt. Und ich denke,
ach, da bist du.
Aber du bist nicht dahingegangen, hast gesagt, könnt ihr bitte auch für mich zu filmen?
Oder hast du gesagt, es reicht,
wenn einer von euch filmt.
Ja genau, sonst sehen die hinter euch nichts.
Zwei von euch können das Handy wieder runternehmen, sonst sehen die Leute hinter euch nichts. Das verstehe ich auch nicht, den Impuls, dass immer alle filmen dann. Wenn ein Freund es filmt, der mit dem besten Handy. Und wir waren da total unerfahren, was diese Clubbing-Szene angeht. Aber man muss ja dann immer so ein bisschen über seinen Wert spielen in so sozialen Situationen. Und dann hieß es so, okay, cool, wir gucken mal, wer heute auflegt, DJ Karotte, was, alter DJ Karotte ist da und alle so, wow, krass, ist da, ist da, crazy, crazy, niemand kannte ihn, niemand kennt ihn auch heute nicht mehr, aber ich weiß noch, dass damals DJ Karotte war live im Q-Club und ich war euphorisiert, ich habe mich selbst durch meine Lüge euphorisiert. Warum heissen DJs immer DJ? Ist ja nicht so, dass, weil der Name auf dem Poster suggeriert schon alles. Ja. Es ist ja irgendwie falsch, dass man dann immer wieder neu, es ist ein bisschen redundant, dass man immer DJ der Schuhe zuhalten muss. Aber ist das nicht so ein IHK-geprüfter Begriff, dass du dich erst DJ Karotte nennen darfst, nachdem du so einen Abschluss hast? DJ ist im Prinzip Journalist, jeder kann es werden, es ist kein geschützter Beruf. Ich dachte, er war lange Karotte und dann endlich, okay, jetzt habe ich meinen Abschluss, jetzt habe ich das Diplom, jetzt darf ich mich DJ Karotte nennen. So wie Doktortitel, da ist ja auch viel Arbeit reingekommen. Du kannst ein Bachelor of Music machen. Bachelor of Music auf DJ Karotte.
Bachelor Karotte.
Ja, das ist dann vielleicht der nächste Schritt.
Karotte MD, Karotte DJ.
Ja, kann man im Prinzip mal überlegen, ob man das einfach weglässt, pauschal.
Spart Tinte.
Ja, spart Bits und Bytes in unserer Zeit, ohnehin wichtig. Wir müssen alle unsere Datenübertragung reduzieren.
Wir müssen uns alle ein bisschen in die Küche treten. Also LOL ist nicht mehr drin. LO ist noch drin. LO ist drin oder halt ein H. Was ist dann oft das so für, dass Leute fragen, wie meinst du das, ach nee, ich wollte Bits und Byte sparen, deswegen ist es eine Kursung von Loll. Was ist dann das so für, dass man ein bisschen mehr schreibt vielleicht sogar. Ja, keine Gifs mehr, nur noch Pics, Pics statt Gifs, keine Gifs mehr. Auch lustig ist es mittlerweile, dass ein Gif sagt mehr als tausend Worte. Dann ist meine Frage, aber sagt dann aber, wenn ein Bild schon mehr als tausend Worte sagt, sagt ein Gif dann nicht ein bisschen mehr, sagt mehr als zweitausend Worte. Das sind rasante Kursschwankungen, wie viel jetzt Worte genau was sagt. Ein Bild gleich mehr als tausend Worte. Du musst ja eigentlich sagen, ein GIF sagt mehr als tausend Bilder. Und ein Bild sagt mehr als tausend Worte. Und dann hast du halt so ein eins zu einer Million. Ein Film sagt zu viel, sagt viel oder viel Error. Ja, ja. Ein Buch sagt wiederum so viel wie ein halbes Wort. Das heißt, da muss man dann ein bisschen gucken. Da muss man auch gucken, obwohl dann die Realität bleibt. Ja, ja, nee, das ist eh schwierig. Das sind eh Fugazi Fugusi, diese Kurse. Mich interessiert das ja eh nicht so. Ich bin, naja, ich versuche mich in der Realwirtschaft zu halten. Ich versuche wirklich Dinge zu schnitzen, Dinge zu wachsen, was ich in der Hand habe. Ja, diese ganzen Fantasiewährungen interessieren mich nicht. Das finde ich gar nicht, ne? Überhaupt nicht. Ich habe einen Eimer voller Geld.
Und wenn jemand sagt, wie viel Geld hast du,
dann sage ich, ich habe genau
einen Eimer.
Wäre es halt wichtig zu wissen, endlich mal, wie viel das wert ist.
Und dafür musst du diesen Eimer
irgendwann mal zur Post, hätte ich was gesagt.
Ja, aber ich habe Angst vor dem Weg.
Ich habe Angst, dass mir der Eimer runterfällt,
dass alles verschüttet wird.
Ab welcher Menge Kleingeld muss man eher ... Könnte das Security anrufen. Also, ab welchem Mindestwert würde man eher versuchen, das wegzuputzen, anstatt aufzusammeln? Verstehst du, wenn jetzt in der Innenstadt eine Wagenladung ein Cent München liegt, da würde jeder mal reingreifen, aber es würde sich relativ
schnell der Enthusiasmus begrenzen.
Und dann kommt die, dann kommt
der Putzdienst,
dann kommen die Strassenreinigungen
und würde das einfach wegreinigen
mit ihren grossen Wirbelbesen
einfach zur Seite. Ich glaube nicht.
Oder würde wirklich man alles aufsammeln?
Ja, ich glaube, es würde alles weggesammelt werden.
Von Bürgern, von Zivilisten. Ja, von Bürgern. Ja, doch durchaus von Bürgern, von der Gesellschaft. Nein, glaube ich nicht. Würde es doch aufgesammelt werden, doch auf jeden Fall. Ein Cent. Ja, nur weil du jetzt hier von deinem hohen Podcastergeldthron herunter posaunst. Nein, das glaube ich nicht. Wenn du wirklich mal so eine Tonne eins, ja aber gut aber gut ja klar natürlich eins auf ja aber du wie viele wie viele würdest du angenommen es läge jetzt ein darf man das eine tonne einst du da mit hocherhobenen armen daneben und sagst nein das ist mein geld nein ich sag nur wenn du du hast du die kölner Innenstadt ja hier ja kützerküll so und dann bist bist du am Marktplatz und da ist so ein riesiger Berg ein Cent Münzen. Wie viele würdest du nehmen, bevor du sagst, jetzt habe ich genug? Nee, einen Eimer. Einen Eimer. Du würdest einen Eimer holen? Ja, ich würde einen Eimer extra holen fahren. Kaufen, ich extra für 11 Euro kaufen. Und dann würde ich in die Sparkasse gehen und dann den da abgeben und sagen, bitte mal einen zahlen und dann mit jetzt mal eine Karte. Und würdest du dann nochmal zurück zu dem Berg, nochmal zurück zu dem Berg gehen oder würdest du es dann dabei belassen? Also es kommt bis auf den Wochentag an, ob ich viel Zeit habe und es kommen auf viele Variablen an. Dann wie gesagt immer noch die Frage, wer hat das da hingelegt, das Geld? Also viele Fragen in diesem Gedankenexperiment. Ja, aber es ist passiert, als die Namen noch alle auf dem Bildschirm standen. Man kann nicht genau sehen, wer das ist. Selbst wenn man sich ganz bemüht und zwischen den Buchstaben guckt, man sieht es nicht. Sind noch andere Menschen da? Ja, es ist ein ganz normaler Tag. Was machen die anderen Menschen? Ja, manche nehmen Abstand, manche greifen zu. Das ist doch mal ein Experiment. Einfach Einfach mal wirklich so, keine Ahnung, ich meine, wie viel kostet eine Tonne ein Cent Münzen?
Wir haben Patreon-Einnahmen, wir können spenden jetzt. Wir haben nie gesagt, wofür wir die genau einsetzen. Die nächsten 10.000 Euro gehen ins grosse Projekt Eine Tonne Liebe, die wir einfach, das ist so das Gegenteil von Helikoptergeld, wo so Geld aus dem Helikopter geworfen wird, wir machen Maulwurfgeld, wo wir so einen grossen Maulwurfhügel, Eins-Händen-Münze machen. Meinst du, da würden richtig Leute kommen mit einer Schaufel und einem Bagger? Ja, natürlich, auf jeden Fall, es wird alles blitzeblank. Und ich sag dir noch was, innerhalb von zwölf Stunden ist der Berg weg. Eine Tonne! Aha. Ja, komplett weg. Kommt auf den Marktplatz an natürlich. Wie viele Leute gehen da lang? Weil natürlich, jeder gibt es nur die Blöße, so einen Eimer voll maximal mitzunehmen. Aber insgesamt ist es total schnell weg. Ich habe jetzt Dinge auf die Strasse gestellt. Ich weiß, wie selbst in Corona-Zeiten sich plötzlich Trauben gebildet haben. Ja, aber nicht mal Argo wurde mitgenommen und jetzt sagst du, was sind zwei Hände voll Centwert, die ging jetzt zu dem Argo. Auch da die Kurse schwanken massiv. Argo wurde nicht mitgenommen, aber meine Staffelei war sehr schnell weg. Ja? War das für dich tragisch, deine Künstlerträume da auf der Strasse zu lassen? Nee, die war so gross, riesig gross und dann, die konnte mehr reingepasst in den Bulli, den einen Bulli, den ich vorgepackt habe. Weil du hast einmal ein Bild in deinem Leben gekauft, das riesengroß war und du dachtest, Bilder sind so gross und bist dann zum Baumarkt gefahren und hast wieder die grösste Staffele gekauft. Ich brauch die grösste Staffelei, die sie hier haben. Nee, das war keine so gute Staffelei, das war so eine Anfängerstaffelei und die war schon ein bisschen älter, dann habe ich die eingestellt. Ist aber eigentlich eine schöne Idee, so einen Strassenverkauf zu haben, so zerbrochene Träume. Und da verkauft er so eine Trompete und eine Staffelei und so Boxhandschuhe und so ein Französisch-Lernbuch und halt wo man wirklich sieht, dass alles kaputt geht. Man fragt sich, was macht er denn jetzt? Was hat er denn jetzt noch? Jetzt trägt er so ein Kimono und lernt Japanisch und du weißt genau. In einem Jahr steht das Kimono da. Kann ich da schon mal nichts drauf haben? Kann ich den jetzt haben oder wollen sie den noch und er zieht den so aus und sagt ja hier. Aber das ist doch genauso wie beim Einkaufen, wo man aufpassen muss, dass man nicht verdächtige Produkte zusammenkauft, wie halt Vaseline, die Gurke und so.
Die Waffe und die Patronen.
Genau, und so ist es ja dann im Gegensatz auch, wenn man die Sachen loswerden will.
Man darf nicht alles zusammentun.
Nein.
Weil sonst weiß man einfach, okay, das war's.
Das ist der verlorene Träumelstand.
Heute ist der Tag, wo er gesagt hat, alle Träume müssen raus.
Kehrt mal durch bei euch.
Macht mal unten so diesen Krümelsammler-Träume leer. einfach mal alles raus. Man sammelt viel, viel Quatsch. Ja, das ist ein guter, also der Umzug war jetzt perfekt dafür, um Sachen hinter sich zu lassen. Ich kann mich auch ein Stück weit jetzt neu erfinden. Nachbarn kann man ein neues Bild von sich mitgeben auf dem Weg, man kann ein neues Leben anfangen auch. Ich habe jetzt schon angefangen, von Tag eins an die Musik jeden Abend ganz doll aufzudrehen, damit es fast so ein Problem wird, wenn die Musik mal nicht läuft. Damit man sich pauschal daran gewöhnt, dass wenn ich mal eine Party mache, niemand sie beschwert, führt jetzt wahrscheinlich dazu, dass wenn die mal leise ist, die Nachbarn kommen und fragen, ist alles gut? Wobei deine Partys ja in der Regel sehr, sehr leise sind, habe ich gehört. Also wenn man sicht, wie war Stephans Party, sehr leise, alle haben die ganze Zeit geflüstert und mussten die Schuhe ausziehen wegen Lärmschutz.
Weil wenn du in den Raum kommst, in dem alle flüstern, fängst du auch einfach an zu flüstern. Du hinterfragst es nicht.
Das habe ich mal in der, da gab es mal ein Café, da gab es noch jetzt, da war die Corona-Zeit noch nicht, da gab es noch ein offenes Café hier in Köln-Ehrenfeld, da bin ich reingegangen und das war unglaublich, also für die Anzahl an Menschen drin waren, unglaublich leise. Und ich dachte mir, weil ich habe es verglichen mit einer Straße, wo plötzlich einer anfängt, rechts dran zu parken. Eine Spur ist einfach jetzt weg, weil da jetzt niemand parkt. Und dann parken andere Autos dahinter und irgendwann ist es eine Parkspur.
Und am nächsten Tag, wenn dann entweder alle abgeschleppt wurden oder wieder alle weggefahren sind,
ist es erst mal wieder eine zweispurige Strasse, bis jemand wieder die Balls hat, sich einfach als Erster hinzustellen.
War es da auch so, also war es erst mal, ist es sonst ein lautes Kaffee und an dem Morgen war einfach der Erste, der da war, leise. Ja. Und dann haben sich alle angepasst und ist es da am nächsten Tag dann lauter wieder, weil das erste Pärchen, was ich hingesetzt hat, direkt ha ha ha, laut geredet hat, wie geht's dir denn, oh, dieser Virus, der wird uns nicht zu nahe kommen, oder nee, das bleibt schön in Asien da. Du, ich weiss genau, was du meinst, und so geht's mir, das ist genau die Problematik, die so schwer zu kommunizieren ist, jedes Mal im Ruheabteil. Ruheabteil und jemand telefoniert am Handy. Und dann sage ich, Entschuldigung, das ist Ruheabteil, hier darf man nicht mit dem Handy telefonieren. Und dann sagt er, ja, aber die anderen sind ja auch laut. Und dann sage ich, ja, aber passen Sie auf, die Dynamik ist folgende, wenn einer anfängt laut zu sein, dann denken die anderen, es ist okay laut zu sein, sind auch laut und das verselbstständigt sich.
Wenn jetzt, verstehen Sie, ihr Verhalten ...
Sie reden schon zehn Minuten auf mich ein, ich muss hier raus.
Das ist ein Kreislauf.
Ich muss hier raus.
Ich hab hier eine Grafik.
Das ist ein Kreislauf.
Sorry.
Und die Tatsache, dass Sie reden, führt dazu, dass Sie einen Grund haben, laut zu reden.
Verstehen Sie, das ist in sich, das ist ein Kreis.
Sie reden genauso laut.
Das ist ein Teufelskreis, weil je mehr, Ruhe jetzt, ich erklär es, weil je mehr Leute laut sind. Und das kann man nicht erklären. Und deswegen glaube ich, also ich glaube, es ist an einer Endstation, bei jeder Endstation ist per Definition der Ruhrabteil der lauteste Abteil. Irgendwann ist es nicht mehr rennbar. Ja, nee, überhaupt nicht. Weil ich glaube, wenn du Regeln brichst, dann richtig. Wenn es im Ruhrabteil laut ist, dann richtig laut, weil du denkst, okay, hier gelten keine Regeln mehr. Die Regeln sind auf den Kopf gestellt. Verbrecher jagen die Polizei, Katzen essen Hunde, hier ist alles erlaubt. Und dann dreht man völlig durch. Zurück zu dem Hundebeispiel. In einem normalen Abteil, da ist es halt laut, dann ist es halt ein lautes Abteil. Aber ich glaube, wenn du eine Grenze übertrittst, dann richtig. Und die Polizisten jagen die Räuber im normalen Teil. Ja, da ist noch alles erlaubt. Ständig, besonders in der zweiten Klasse. Da ist ja immer was los. Ja, wild, also die Leute, die zweiten Klasse. Aber es ist genau so, so stelle ich es mir jedes Mal vor, wenn so ein Bahnschaffender oder Kontrolleur am Morgen in den Zug steigt und er ist ganz leer und er streicht so mit einer Hand über die noch saubere, glatte Klobrille und sagt, welcher Tag wird heute wohl sein? Wie wird sich das heute entwickeln? Es ist jeden Tag neu. Es kommt immer nur auf den ersten Menschen an, der die Macht hat. Also da muss man sich aber auch mal ihr da draußen noch mal bewusst werden, was für eine Macht wir alle haben, als Leute, die etwas anfangen. Anfänger sind die mächtigsten Leute, einfach weil eure Position euch so mächtigen Menschen macht. Deswegen sch unter YouTube-Videos Erster, weil man sich dessen bewusst ist, dass man den Ton vorgibt. Wenn ich jetzt nerv, nerven alle. Eigentlich ist es damit schon zerstört, weil man sieht, okay, hier sind nur Crap-Kommentare, und man hat schon direkt verloren. Ich finde, deswegen ist Erster gerade ein schlechtes Beispiel, weil das macht alles kaputt, da sind die Leute sich nicht ihrer Verantwortung bewusst. Der erste Kommentar ist
die Musik, so spielt die Musik.
Macht die Musik.
Wie man in die Musik hineinbläst,
bleibt der Teppich
in der Kirche, im Dorf.
Das wissen wir
alle. Ach herrlich, lassen wir
Teppich in der Kirche. Ich habe eine Freundin,
die andauernd
Gespräch wieder nur halb sagt. Weil sie denkt, das macht man so. Sprichwörter sagt man nur halb. Ach so. Wo gehobelt wird, ne? Ja. Und ich will die ganze Zeit sagen, fallen Späne. Lass uns das zumindest zu Ende bringen, weil es ist nicht, und dann habe ich gesagt, fallen Späne. Ja, ja. Und dann hat sie gesagt, hat gesagt, ja, ja, ich weiß, ich habe es doch gerade gesagt. Und sie hat gesagt, nein, wo gehobelt wird. Das ist kein vollständiger Satz. Und sie hat dann für zehn Minuten uns doll gestritten, weil sie behauptet hat, nein, sprich, da sagt man immer nur halb. Also wer einer eine Kuh bekräbt, fällt selbst hine hinein! Ja, ich weiss! Ja, dann sag's doch! Aber es stimmt schon, manche sagt man, so wie es in den Wald hineinschallt. Ich kann das nicht ertragen, das ist so wie, wenn man die Musik nicht zu Ende spielt oder so, der letzte Ton spielt. Oh mein Gott! Das ist so unvollendet. Ja, ich verstehe schon. Ich mag das gar nicht. Sagt, das ist zu Ende. Ich kann das noch nicht ertragen, wenn ich den Satz nicht zu Ende spreche, und dann unterbricht mich schon jemand, weil er weiß, in welche Richtung der Satz geht. Und dann vollende ich das halt. Dann selber noch. Ich muss nur eine Geschichte denken, die du erzählt hast, wie du Quiz spielst mit deiner Alexa oder deinem Google und jemand eine Frage in den Raum stellt. Oder nee, sie stellt die Frage? Sie stellt mir Fragen. Genau. Und du antwortest und dann passiert gar nichts mehr, oder was? Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau. Ich habe jedenfalls entdeckt, es war nachts und es war dunkel, stockdunkel und ich lag halt noch im Bett und habe dann angefangen mit Alexa dieses Quiz zu spielen. Aber irgendwann hat sie aufgehört. Ich finde das so lustig. Irgendwann haben wir aufgehört, das zu spielen und dann war es ruhig. Aber allein diese Vorstellung, dass deine Stimmerkennung sich nicht erkennt, du liegst im Bett und denkst, wie alt ist Keanu Reeves?
Die Antwort nicht. Stimmt. Und du, das war's, glaube ich. Schläfst ein. Das war's. Das war's. Das war's. Das war's. Das war's. Das war's. Das war's. Ja, weil man wiederholt es auch nur zweimal. Und wenn dann irgendwann, wenn es dann noch einmal kommt, dann ist es falsch. Und dann ist es so, wie gross ist Tom Hanks? Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, da in Eins zu schlafen. Das ist wirklich wie so eine Energie im Raum. Das geht jetzt nicht. Das ist wie wenn Leute essen und bevor sie den Happen nehmen noch was ansagen, dann weiß niemand, ob man jetzt weiterredet. Ja, auf jeden Fall, ich habe zu ihr gesagt, oh mein Gott. Und du, ab wann? Und er fängt auch was anderes an, wenn er fertig ist, hat er was anderes. Trinkt. Mega better heute und trinkt dann noch. Und alle am Tisch kratzen mit der Gabel über. Ich habe auch einen Kollegen, der mal was sagen will, der mit so einem mhm beim Essen, also wenn man aufkaut, kann man ja schon mal die Aufmerksamkeit auf sich ziehen, mit so einem m m oder weiss man, okay, er will etwas sagen, Aufmerksamkeit auf ihn, m und dann der nächste Bissen in den Mund, das macht er häufig. Das ist sadistisch. Und man denkt so, what, das ist Narzissmus, wenn man nämlich isst, m und dann der nächste Bissen und er hat die Aufmerksamkeit bei allen unterbrechen Sätze, weil man mit dem, quasi auf den Knopf drückt jetzt. Und dann Salzstreuer. Ich sag was Knopf. Ja, und dann Salzstreuer. Trinkenst du? Und dann wieder, man denkt, what? Das geht jetzt nicht. Probiert das mal, na gut, jetzt werden wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so viele Leute zusammen essen, aber probiert das mal aus, wie lange man das machen kann, bevor Leute einfach gehen. Waren sie nicht werden. Wenn du wirklich sagst und dann wirklich einfach nach zehn, zwanzig Minuten und das ist grossartig. Das ist eigentlich schön, wie lange wird es dauern. Weil daran siehst du, wenn man das offen anspricht, euer Partner, dann habt ihr eine gute Beziehung, wenn der Partner irgendwann wirklich einfach wütend wird und geht, dann ist vielleicht nochmal die Beziehung überdenkenswert. Ich hatte es aber auch mal, ich will sehr privat, aber mit einer Dame im Bett und dann ist man, geht man, schläft man ein, ohne sich Gute Nacht zu sagen, was ich wahnsinnig lustig finde, weil der Tag nicht abmoderiert wird. Genau. Und was hat daraus resultiert, weil Gute Nachtsagen ist eigentlich so so ein bisschen eine Tradition, denk, dachte ich immer, die albernd ist. Warum? Die Gesellschaft gibt das davor, aber das war Quatsch, das sollte man nur darüber nachdenken. Die Gesellschaft gab es schon davor. Die Gesellschaft gibt das vor, dass man Gute-Nacht-Sagen kennt und so. Wenn man es aber nicht macht, ist es wirklich acht Stunden lang peinliches Schweigen miteinander. Peinlich einen in die Nacht starren. Es ist der Unterschied zwischen Schweigen und Pause. Weil wenn du normal redest und aufhörst zu reden, dann ist es nur eine Pause. Aber sobald du sagst Gute Nacht, dann ist es danach keine Pause mehr, sondern es ist aus. Und ich musste lachen dann, weil irgendwann so, man könnte dann einfach um drei Uhr nachts weiterreden und es wäre nicht falsch. Ja, ja. Weil die Pause, es war nur eine Pause. Ja, ja. Und dann hat er wirklich gesagt und sie schreckt auf. Du, jetzt wo ich nochmal, aber das ist, muss man nicht noch machen. Wo ich nochmal drüber nachdenke, das wird doch nicht so richtig. Ja, ja, ja. Was, was? Und ich dachte jetzt, du sagst, man sagt nichts und dann um drei und nachts gut nach. Aus dem Nichts einfach. Schon vier Stunden Stille. Ich meine, vier Stunden zusammengeballter V, das habe ich auch oft bei WhatsApp-Konversationen, dass man dann nicht mehr schreibt und dann schreibt die andere Person so, ja, bin jetzt jedenfalls duschen. Und dann so, ja, voll okay. Ja. Oder ja, gute Nacht. Ja. Und dann auch so, ja, dann mach's gut. Okay, du auch. Ja, genau. Furchtbar. Es ist furchtbar. Ja. Mittlerweile ist auch interessant, wie viel man dann schreibt und wie viel ... Manche Menschen finde ich eine andere Beziehung schriftlich als oral, mündlich. Ich finde es teilweise schwierig mit ... Ich denke an manche Menschen, mit denen kann ich nicht gut schreiben, gar nicht gut schreiben. Wir haben keine gute schriftliche Basis, aber eine sehr gute in-Pis, wo man sagt, das ist aber krass, eigentlich muss eine moderne Freundschaft beides können, weil eine moderne Freundschaft muss ja fast mehr schriftlich geführt werden. Das finde ich auch interessant. Ich schreibe auch mit jedem anders, da bin ich so ein Chameleon. Ja, es ist total, wenn man sich überlegen würde, mit jemandem, mit dem man nur gut schreibt und gar nicht gut spricht oder andersrum. Was ist besser? Bestimmt. So ein Partner, so Herzblatt. Wir haben Annika, sie kann überhaupt nicht schreiben, nutzt immer die falschen Emojis, macht immer noch so merkwürdige Nachfragen, aber im Umgang vielleicht. Oder wir haben Bianca, sie schreibt fantastisch, wunderbarer Wortwitz, Wortspiele, hört immer genau im richtigen Moment auf, aber in Angesicht zu Angesicht kein geraden Satz. Gar nichts. Nichts peinliches Schweigen, peinliches Schweigen, merkwürdige Themen. Hi Bianca. Hm? Nee, ja, ist gut. Wen, wer darf es sein, Annika oder Bianca? Annika. Annika? Ja, aber ich glaube, der behaupte, ich kann nicht so richtig gut schreiben und so. Wenn ich mir auch rückblickend dann sowas, ich verstehe immer nicht, warum der Gegenüber dann immer so sauer wird beim Schreiben oder so auf mich oder oder man dann so, und dann liest man nochmal mit Abstand emotional distanziert diesen Verlauf und denkt, ja, du bist einfach ein Vollidiot. Das war ja auch nicht zu verstehen, weil ich gebe mir auch nicht so viel Mühe. Ja, ja, stimmt. Wenn ich mir Mühe gebe, das ist ja von Thomas Mann, der gesagt hat, Autoren sind diejenigen, denen Schreiben im schwersten fällt. Und wenn ich anfange, mir Gedanken zu machen und das als gerade schriftliche Selbstverwirklichung wahrnehme, dauert das ewig. Ja. Und und deswegen fällt mir Schreiben glaube ich wirklich schwer und deswegen fange ich an, das so wegzuspielen und das auch nicht als Sprache oder Schreiben zu verstehen, sondern eher so als weggesprochen. Eher so Körpersprache über Schrift, einfach so der Technische. Impulsiv weg. Und dann liest man es nochmal durch und denkt man, das funktioniert so. So Punkte schreiben ja auch gar nicht.
Nee, spätestens wenn man ein Textdokument aufmacht, um den Text zu schreiben, um ihn dann ins Chatprogramm zu kopieren, weiss man, das wird nichts mehr.
Aber das passiert häufig.
Klar, allein diese Punkte, wenn der andere schreibt, dann denkst du dir, was denkt der eigentlich, was ich für ein Vollidiot bin? Punkte, Punkte, Punkte, nichts.
Punkte, Punkte, Punkte, wieder nichts. Zehn Minuten Stille, dann Punkte, Punkte, Punkte, ganz lange, nichts für, haha, ja genau. Genau. So, der denkt sich, bist du komplett bescheuert eigentlich? Ja, aber auch andersrum komisch, wenn so ein ganz langer Text kommt und davor waren keine Punkte, ganz kurze Punkte. Manche machen das aber auch aus, dass man die Punkte nicht sieht. Das geht nicht. Geht nicht. Gar nicht? Ich bin mir sicher, dass es nicht geht. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe alles ausgestellt, was geht. Ich habe alles ausgestellt. Man sieht bei mir nicht, wann ich zuletzt online war, man sieht bei mir nicht, ob ich was gelesen habe oder nicht. Die beste Entscheidung meines Lebens war, auszustellen, dass ich Nachrichten gesehen habe. Weil es gibt nichts Unangenehmes als, du hast es doch gelesen. Ja, das Problem ist halt, wann stellt man das aus? Weil man muss es eigentlich zwischen Kontakten ausstellen. Weil wenn du mit jemandem, du hast ja immer so Phasen, es überlappt sich ja so, so wie Komponisten der Zeit. Dann hat der eine Zeit, dann fängt der neu an. Und so hat man ja auch Kontakte. Und es ist aber schwierig, den Punkt zu treffen, wo man das umstellt. Weil ich will nicht die Person sein, wir lernen uns kennen, schreiben, schreiben, schreiben, schreiben, schreiben, schreiben und dann stelle das aus. Bin ich jetzt der Grund, warum man es ausstellt? Bin ich so schlecht? Und deswegen glaube ich, habe ich noch nie den Punkt gefunden, wo ich sage, jetzt schalte ich es aus. Bis heute. Tipp, einfach mal eine Freundschaft kurz on hold setzen. Ja? Kurz mal einen Streit vom Zaun brechen. Ja? Ja. Ja, du hast ja gesehen, ich bin nicht so gut im Streiten. Das habe ich wirklich gesehen. Anrüpeln. Wirklich ganz schlecht im Streiten. Ja, ich habe es versucht, dich anzustreiten. Ich bin sauer auf dich, dass du nicht so schlecht im Streiten bist. Ja, ich habe versucht, dich anzustreiten, aber anscheinend ist es auch nicht angekommen. Nee, wann? Ja, ich wollte ein bisschen zank. Wann warst du denn sauer? Nee, ich habe halt so ein bisschen schnippisch geschrieben.
Okay, dann nehmen wir halt um 18 Uhr auf.
Aber das kam anscheinend nicht an.
Dann nehmen wir gerne um 18 Uhr auf.
Ja, aber es war halt ein schnippisches.
Gerne.
Ja.
Lass solche Wörter weg wie gerne oder so.
Gern.
Das kommt nicht an, du bist nicht gut im Streiten.
Du bist so schnippisch.
Ja, ich dachte, ich versuche immer so ein bisschen.
Du bist so liebevoll.
Ja, das ist eigentlich genau das Gegenteil gemeint. Aber ich weiß es nicht, es ist schwierig. Ja, man muss es smooth gut schreiben können. Man muss auch gut skypen können. Man kann auch viele Tricks anwenden. Das ist eine hohe Kunst. Jetzt Homeoffice können alle mal Tricks anwenden. Man kann nämlich ganz gut das Gesicht freezen. Und dann so tun, als man kann einfach so tun, als wäre Skype eingefroren. Das hat man ja häufig, dass plötzlich ein Kollege was sagt und dann plötzlich nichts mehr sagt und dann so das Gesicht so einfriert in so einem komischen, man sieht ja auch komisch aus, wenn man spricht und inmitten eines Worts ist man dann plötzlich eingefroren. Das kannst du ja auch faken. Übt es mal zu Hause, aber wenn ihr nicht mehr wollt, wenn ihr irgendwie so weggedost seid, reden die seit zehn Minuten weiter und irgendwann so, oder Stefan, wie siehst du das? Und du sagst so, du machst so auf, dann kann man sich gut retten, indem man sagt, na ja, ich will. Und dann einfach auflegen. Das geht nicht, dann sieht man deine Hand ja. Ach so, na ja gut, komm doch, wenn du die Kamera einstellst. Das ist ja Schritt eins. Ach so, du machst so Laptop, okay. Laptop, ja, schwierig dann. Ich habe eine Webcam, das ist, glaube ich, der absolute Trumpf. Webcam zu haben ist der absolute Trumpf. Aber da musst du es trotzdem, bei dem Gesicht merkt man viel, also auch wenn du dann plötzlich den Arm bewegst oder so. Ja, bei mir ist die Situation immer so, ich habe meinen Monitor und an meinen Laptop angeschlossen. Ich schaue auf den Monitor, der Laptop steht aber links neben mir. Das heißt, die Webcam ist ja am Laptop, das heißt, der Laptop filmt nicht immer im Profil. Das heißt, die Leute sehen mich immer im Profil und ich rede auf den Monitor ein, aber nicht auf die Webcam. Das heißt, alle schauen sich gerade ins Gesicht. Warum machst du die Webcam nicht auf den Monitor? Das ist, wenn ich den Laptop benutze. Der Laptop steht halt auf dem Tisch links, den kann ich ja nicht über den Monitor klemmen oder so. Der steht halt links. Und das so, alle schauen gerade in die Kamera, nur ich mal wie so ein Gefangenenprofil. Und alle so, hey, hier, hier, hallo. Und wahrscheinlich ist es so ein ganz asynchrones Machtverhältnis, dass alle Leute denken so, warum guckt der mich nicht an, ich gucke ihn an, was ist da so Interessantes dabei?
Wir hatten ja mal. Ich finde es lustig,
wenn man diesen Trick macht mit dem Freeze,
so, oder Stefan, wie siehst du das?
Ach so, ja, also ich,
dann freeze man ein, im Hintergrund läuft aber dann irgendwie so die Katze
vorbei oder so.
Und man sagt so, stopp,
halt, stopp.
Wir haben mal in der, damals, in der legendären Frank-Elsa-Masterclass, hatten wir immer so weirde Dozenten teilweise, manchmal nur für einen Tag, die uns Sachen beigebracht haben. Und da war ein Tag so jemand da, der uns beigebracht hat, wie man das perfekte Profilbild macht. Na, was ist denn seine Berufsbezeichnung gewesen? Fotograf, Profilbildmacher.
Ja, ich weiss es nicht, aber halt so Social Media Experte so und der hat auch und der meinte dann so und wir haben das halt so hingenommen, da hat niemand überlegt, warum ist das jetzt so und dann hat er uns einfach erzählt, ja, gibt einen ganz grossen Unterschied zwischen Männern und Frauen. Frauen sollen beim Profilbild in die Kamera schauen und Männer sollen gerade nicht in die Kamera schauen, sondern so an der Kamera vorbei oder so seitlich oder so, weil das anscheinend besser ankommt.
Weil, also zumindest aufs Gegengeschlecht, sage ich mal, weil Männer wollen direkt angeguckt werden im Sinne von Ich bin der Tolle von Frauen, wohingegen, wenn die Frau das Bild anguckt und der Mann wegschaut, ist sie sozusagen interessiert im Sinne von, warum guckt er mich nicht an, das war so seine Logik, so hat er es erklärt, das ist wahrscheinlich völliger Unsinn, aber das war die Logik dahinter, dass er sagt, wer nicht in die Kamera guckt, erweckt das Bedürfnis, ah, ich will dich erobern, ich will dich beeindrucken, wohingegen, wenn man direkt angeguckt wird, von der anderen Seite, dann ist das toll.
Und das haben wir uns dann angehört und gesagt,
ja gut, ich habe so einen kleinen,
ich habe Bart Simpson,
den Messer in der Hand hat als Profilbild.
Ich habe einen verpixelten Bart Simpson.
Aber wenn man überlegt, wo die Augen sind,
könnte es schon sein, dass er nicht in die Kamera.
Guckt nicht in die Kamera.
Guckt mit seinem 2D-Gesicht nicht in die Kamera.
Und das ist so, wo man denkt, okay, diese ganze Überlegung geht komplett an mir vorbei. Aber ja, ich hab ja bei Telegram zum Beispiel ein sterbendes E.T. als Profilbild. Weil ich es mal lustig fand. Das E.T. An irgendeinem Punkt im Film stirbt er ja fast und liegt in so einem Kanal und ist einfach so eine widerliche, eklige Wurmgestalt und weil es halt dieser schöne Film ist E.T. und viele haben verbinden mit E.T. was und ist in der Popkultur groß und so Profilbilder aber ich hab halt mich für E.T. entschieden, weil ich lustig fand, das stört. Das schlechtmöglichste aber er sagt immer noch, ich bin ein E.T. Fan eigentlich was Süßes, aber es ist halt ähm, ist der sterbende E.T. entschieden, weil ich lustig fand, er stört. Das schlechtmöglichste Bild. Aber er sagt immer noch, ich bin ein E.T. Fan, eigentlich was Süsses, aber es ist halt der sterbende E.T. Oder so ein E.T. unscharf von hinten in so einer Szene, wo man ja mal im Hintergrund ist und das daneben so. Ich liebe E.T. Aber es ist bei mir einfach dieser nackte, sterbende E.T. blass und dann habe ich neulich aber mal über Telegram mit einer Person schreiben müssen, die dann krank wurde, sehr schlimm. Und die sah auch so ein bisschen wurmig aus, oder wie? Naja, er war einfach super krank. Und diese Person, die ich nicht gut kannte, wir waren aber so ein bisschen über so eine Situation verbunden, musste ich dann schreiben, oh, ich hoffe, dir geht's gut. Und dann fiel mir so ein, ach Gott, aber wenn ich jetzt das Bild rausnehme, ist auch kein gutes Zeichen. Das habe ich ja die ganze Zeit schon als Telegram-Profilbild, das sterbende E.T. Aber jetzt wirkt es ein bisschen, wenn sie es vorher nicht gesehen hat, wirkt es jetzt ein bisschen so, ah shit. Ja, wenn du es jetzt auf Garfield änderst, ist die Frage, was ist das wieder für eine Kommende, als Zeichen. Geht es mir so schlecht, dass ich Garfield brauche, dass ich nicht sterbende Etik kriege? Ja, genau. Aber jetzt auch da ist ein bisschen falsches Signal, das sterbende Etik. Deswegen mit Witzen, ich isse nicht mehr so mein, nee, ich heutzut. Nee, du distanzierst dich von Humor. Ich distanziere mich mit Humor von Humor. Ich glaube, auch neutrale Profilbilder sind das das Beste. Einfach wirklich so ein Mandala, einfach so ein Mosaik oder so ein rotes Quadrat. So ein Anime-Ding, so eine Anime- rotes quadrat oder halt einfach wirklich so eine abstrakte form so ein grünes dreieck wo man sich denkt ja ist vielleicht irgendwie immer grün ich finde dreiecke okay drei ist die perfekte anzahl an ecken meiner Meinung nach finde ich eine gute Anzahl an ecken vier geht vielleicht auch gerade noch fünf ist zu viel keine im Kreis drei nee nee nee nee nee nee zwischen drei und vier ist, ne, ne, ne. Zwischen drei und vier ist die perfekte, so dreieinhalb Eck, so dreieinhalb Eck, das wäre perfekt, aber. Gibt es halbe Ecken? Ja, da ist sich die Mathematik noch uneinig momentan. Das ist auch ein ungelöstes Rätsel. Ja, ja, da wird geforscht, was ist überhaupt eine Ecke, ne, gibt es eine halbe Ecke und wenn es nur so ein bisschen ist, so 179 Grad, ist es eine Ecke oder ist es eher so ein Knick oder wie macht. Ja, also wie gesagt, wir sind da noch nicht sehr weit gekommen und wir bräuchten fürs nächste Jahr dann noch mehr Forschungsgelder, wenn es geht. Noch ein bisschen Geld, bitte. Werbung Endlich da, lange warten wir schon drauf. Alles das kannst du gucken und viele Serien, unter anderem The Mandalorian. Yes. Tolle Serie, auch in diesem Podcast besprochen worden. Und weißt du, was das Beste ist? Du kannst alle Sachen auch gleichzeitig gucken. Alle vier Sachen, die du gerade aufgezählt hast, kannst du gleichzeitig gucken. Du bist auf bis zu vier Screens gleichzeitig. Ich kann Mulan auf vier Screens gleichzeitig schauen. Oder das. Wie gut ist das denn? Wir haben auch schon The Mandalorian besprochen, auch das gibt es natürlich da, exklusiv, das ganze Marvel-Universum, also tobt euch aus und viel Spaß mit Disney+. Und weiterhin mit der Folge. Werbung. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass alle Projekte, die jetzt gerade entstehen, so über Skype und so, da haben wir in der nächsten Zeit viel Schrott auch vor uns, um ehrlich zu sein. Ja. Ich habe das Gefühl, viele Startups, die so weirden Scheiss machen, so verkopften Kack. Ich glaube, das wird auch eine neue ... Also alles, was ich gerade produziere, kann ich euch sagen, ist grober Unsinn. Ja. Ich komme zu nichts, ich warte auf die nächste Pause, ich bin, man fängt dann an, irgendwie rumzurödeln, Regal aufzubauen oder sowas. Die Drehs sind sehr unangenehm, weil alle ganz weit auseinanderstehen müssen. Ganz merkwürdig, der Tonmann hat eine ganz, ganz lange Angel. Alle fangen an zu angeln, Catering hat solche Angeln. Alles, was ich gerade schreibe, was irgendwann mal rauskommt vielleicht, oh mein Gott, ganz grober Quatsch, grober, grober Quatsch. Alles, was jetzt gerade in meinem Homeoffice entsteht, ich bin da nicht gut drin. Ich brauche diese Disziplin, zur Arbeit zu gehen. Was jetzt gerade entsteht, ist ganz grober Unsinn. Nee, du kannst nicht arbeiten, wenn neben dir so ein Teller Jaffa-Cakes steht und du einfach weißt, im Kühlschrank habe ich noch zwei weitere Packungen. Ja, oder du siehst so ungespültes Geschirr. Du hast ja auch viele Aufgaben im Heim. Das ist ja auch ein Arbeitsplatz. Ich muss das trennen, sonst fange ich dann an, rumzurödeln. Ja, ja, ja. Das geht nicht, da kommst du nicht zu Kram.
Deswegen glaube ich, wenn ich so arbeite, wie alle anderen arbeiten im Homeoffice, dann Prost Mahlzeit, dann bricht die Welt aber bald zusammen. Ich glaube, das wird eine neue, so eine Kunst Epoche, so Impressionismus, Ex-Moderne so und dann jetzt gibt es eine Kunst Epoche, einfach Koronialismus. Postkoronialismus. Koronialismus. Ja, oder halt einfach so Crap, halt einfach so die Schrott, da ist halt nur Crap entstanden.
Weil das ärgert mich immer bei diesen Kunst-Epochen, dass sie einem nicht helfen, die Spreu von Weizen zu trennen. Du hast halt so, ja, Impressionismus, da ging es darum, das zu repräsentieren und Atmosphäre zu kehren. Und nicht so, sag mir, was gut ist und was schlecht. Sag mir, die Epoche war kompletter Rotz. Also da waren Leute am Lenker, die hatten keine Ahnung. Dann kamen wieder gute Leute. Und deswegen glaube ich, wenn jetzt eine Epoche kommt, wo man einfach weiß, skippt das. Wenn du so die Geschichte des Films hast, du hier so zwölf Jahre, die du einfach skippen kannst, weil es nur Nonsen sind. Die 90er vielleicht, da sagt man, okay, das war echt schade. Musik, der Musik, der kommt ein bisschen auf die 90er, wobei genere alles, ne, doch, die 90er, Filme. Ich meine, Nelly Furtado war gut, aber der Rest war echt crap. Ich bin auch nicht, ich bin auch nicht Nelly Furtado. Die 90er kann man komplett vergessen. Da müssen aber alle auch mal sagen, da haben wir uns alle verrannt. Ja, absolut. Da sind wir alle in die falsche Richtung. Und das ist halt eine Trash-Epoche. Und ich glaube, jetzt kommt, obwohl, ich glaube, für eine Trash-Epoche hätten wir jetzt zu wenig Energie. Jetzt ist es zu ernst irgendwie. Ich glaube, 90er war sehr unbedarf. Nee, jetzt so eine ... Und es war dann zu hyperaktiv, zu kindisch. Ja, so eine Homeoffice-Woche, so eine Epoche, so eine, ja, schwierig zu beschreiben, aber so dahingemurschtelt. Ja, wenn du wirklich sagst ... Wurschtel-Epoche. Wenn du sagst, ich bin Kunsthistoriker, ich spezialisiere mich auf die Wiener Moderne. Oh, okay, wow, toll, interessant. Ich bin Kunsthistoriker, ich spezialisiere mich auf die Neunziger. Die Neunziger, dem hast du dein Leben verschrieben? Ja, halt so ein bisschen ironisch, Nelly Furtado, ne komm, die Neunziger. Und jetzt, das wird es auch sein, alle Leute, die sich um die heutige Zeit kümmern, die werden halt verlacht in ihren Universitäten, Fakultäten. Ja, oder geboren werden.
Ausgeworfen.
Geboren werden so jetzt im Oktober 2020.
Ja.
Coronials.
Die werden auch, da wird auch immer gelacht werden.
Ja.
Oh, brauchst du ein Virus, damit deine Eltern mal, ne, sowas.
Wird sich auch gut lustig gemacht werden, bin ich mir sehr sicher.
Apropos schlechte Ideen, ich habe letzte Woche ja davon geredet, dass mir eine neue Domain angeboten wurde. Worst Bird! Worst Bird! Und manche haben es vielleicht schon erfahren, ja, ich habe zugeschnappt. Worst Bird ist in meiner Hand, mir gehört diese Website, uns gehört diese Website vielleicht als GbR Landingpage. Und ja, ich gebe mir gerne natürlich einen Einblick in die Verhandlungsprozesse. Wenn man noch vor einer Woche auf worstbird.com gegangen wäre, dann hätte man gesehen, diese Domain kostet 2350 Dollar. Das war der Preis, der dir angeboten wurde, oder? Mir wurde angeboten, wir haben jetzt Special Offer 235 Dollar. Was? Wo man merkt, wow, das ist mal ein Special Offer. 10% des Preises. Aber die Margen sind auch bei 100%, muss man sagen. Ja, wow, das ist, ja stimmt, Produktionskosten null. Null. Gewinn, 2.053 Dollar. Und dann erst war es Kate, aber Kate, dann habe ich mit Kate ein bisschen geschrieben und irgendwann hat dann Raymond übernommen. Raymond? Und ich habe schon gemerkt, oh, mit Raymond ist ein anderer Ton. Mit Kate so, hey, how you doing, hey, darling, so, alles in Ordnung. Darling! Look, look, I only got fifty dollars, it's a tough time. Wieder, du hast wieder gemacht, ich hab nur fünfzig. Ich hab nur fünfzig und Kate meinte so, ah, I can look what I can do, I talk to my manager und so. Ist Raymond der Manager? Möglich, möglich und dann irgendwann sagt sie, ja, ich kann vielleicht auch zweihundert Dollar runter, irgendwie, great, 200 Dollar runter irgendwie. Und ich so, look Kate, to be honest, I got 50 bucks. That's it, that's it. I got 50 bucks. Und dann kam Raymond. 50 bucks will ich auch nicht schreiben, weil es klingt noch weniger als 50 Dollar. Ja, ich habe 50 Kröten. Nee, ich will 50 Euro. Und dann kam Raymond und meinte, look, I got a special, unique offer for you, this is it, like, we've worked for this offer, we worked for you, we put it in a good word, 150 dollars. Und ich, Raymond, got to be honest with you, look at it, look, you gotta look at it from my perspective, man, I got 50 dollars. Oh, egal! Ist es diese Filmszene oder ist es irgendeine Sitcom-Episode, wo der andere immer noch mehr, das ist glaube ich so eine Seinfeld-Episode, wo George die ganze Zeit sagt, nee, wir müssen noch ein bisschen runtergehen. Ja, genau, mit seiner Serie. Und Jerry die ganze Zeit hat, nein, wir können das nicht machen, wir müssen es annehmen. Und du bist genauso, ich will so an dir rütteln. Nee, absolut nur. Nee, hundertfünfzig doll, ich habe gesagt, look, Raymond, I can send you a picture of my wallet, there just is one clean crisp 50 dollar bill in it, nothing more, that's it. Und er, ja, ja, ein paar Tage später, 100 dollars, und ich, Raymond, look, this is, this is not going well. Oh mein Gott, ich kann mir das nicht glauben, es ist okay 100 Euro ist super! Fifty dollars is all I have. I sold everything, I sold Argo, everything I have. Fifty dollars for a worse bird, I don't have any more. Und dann kam die E-Mail, are you willing to buy today for fifty dollars? Raymond, yes I am. Das gibt's nicht. Hell yes I am. Raymond, you're the man. Ich will mit dir in so ein Autohaus gehen, weil ohne Scheiss deine penetrantes Deadpan ich hab nur 50. Scheint nur 50. Wie oft hast du denn nur 50? Das ist die beste Verhandlungsposition, wenn du sagst, pass auf, es geht hier gar nicht um Verhandlungstaktik und so, ich habe einfach nicht mehr, ich kann nicht mehr zahlen, es ist gar nicht in meiner Möglichkeit, ich kann nicht mehr zahlen. Er hat gesagt, willst du heute kaufen, er hat gesagt, hell yes, hat er mir einen Link geschickt, zugegriffen, 50 Dollar. 50 Dollar, 30 Euro oder so. Ist das die erste Worst Bird Production Folge? Ja, kann sein, wir haben noch keinen Jingle.
Doch, den sprechen wir nachher ein.
Auf jeden Fall, Worst Bird Productions ist auf jeden Fall online.
Oh mein Gott.
Und wir haben ihn momentan, es ist noch ein bisschen schwierig, weil der sitzt auf seiner amerikanischen Domain Provider Service Seite.
Ich habe es noch nicht ganz gecheckt, muss es erst umziehen, aber auch gehen wir hin.
Ob wir gerade überhaupt so einen Namensänderungsantrag durchbekommen, weil gerade die ganzen anderen Firmen in unserer Situation, die ganzen anderen Unterhalter, wir antragen gerade alle die Corona-Soforthilfe. Ja, vielleicht kriegen wir dann aus Versehen auch die Hilfe. Und wir rufen dann so an und sagen, ja, wollen Sie die Hilfe? Ne, wir wollen einen Namen ändern in Worssburg. Ich habe 20 andere Anrufer an der Leitung. Wie viel Geld brauchen Sie? Wie sehr sind Sie betroffen?
Fünftausend, zehntausend Euro.
Nee, gerne für andere ausgeben.
Sagen Sie irgendeine Zahl, Sie kriegen so viel Geld, wie Sie wollen.
Hunderttausend Euro. Gefällt Ihnen der Name Worssburg?
Jetzt. Hunderttausend, ich habe noch drei, ich habe drei schreiende Kinder,
hunderttausend. Wir haben fünfzig, wir sind...
Fünfzigtausend, fünfzigtausend Dollar.
Oh mein Gott.
Nee, uns geht's gut, wir haben fünf. 50.000, 50.000 Dollar. Oh mein Gott. Ne, uns geht's gut, wir haben 50 Dollar. Ja, und naja, es kann gut sein. Es wird echt schwierig, schlechtes Timing jetzt zu kommen. Oder das Beste. Ja, kann auch sein. Naja, mal schauen, aber wir haben die Seite auf jeden Fall, wir haben noch keine schlechten Vögel gefunden. Ich habe einen, warte mal, ich habe einen Kandidaten für einen schlechten Vogel. Du hast gerade gesagt, wer hat eine Einsendung, hast du gesagt, wolltest du mir nicht zu viel verraten. Ist die Einsendung der Vogel? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ach so. Nee, warte mal, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich diesen Vogel, weil ich habe mal so ein bisschen geguckt, ein bisschen recherchiert, so was man so findet an schlechten Vögeln. Ja, es gibt schon einige schlechte Vögel. Und so, und ja, ist weg. Ja, ist weg. Oh, ich kann jetzt, in meiner neuen Wohnung, schaue ich direkt auf den Fischreiher. Da ist andauernd ein riesiger, riesiger Fischreiher. Was ein tolles Tier. Aber ist ein Reiher ein Fisch oder ist es so eine Art Fischteich? Ich weiß nicht, was ein Reier ist. Ein Vogel, ein Fischreier.
Ach so. Ein Weiher meinst du.
Ja. Du meinst ein Fischweiher.
Auweiher, dachte ich.
Nein, ich meine ein Fischreiher, ist ein sehr schöner Vogel, das ist der Best Bird.
Können wir uns doch Best Bird übrigens kaufen?
Best Bird wird tatsächlich auch verkauft, aber es ist kein Preis angeschrieben, also müsste man nachfragen.
Kannst du sagen, wir haben 50 Dollar?
Und dann ist Frau Dray Raymond so zurück, dude, dude, dude, I fought for you, man, I showed my boss the picture of your wallet, well, warum hat Raymond nicht mehr gefragt, aber wie hast du dich kaufen? Was ist das Leben, das du lebst? Was essen wir? Ja, wie hast du dich kaufen? Hast du noch 50 Dollar morgen? Wenn ja, wie hast du deinen Tag gespürt? Ja,, stimmt. Was hast du gestern gemacht?
Nichts.
Ich habe zieler Websites gestern.
Das ist alles, was ich mache.
Websites bought, ziel.
Vielleicht schreibt er auch in der Woche so,
Dude, bist du okay?
Du spielst jetzt all dein Geld auf Wurzburg.
War es es wert? Ich fühle mich irgendwie I sold you the website for 50, 50 dollars. Yeah, naja, aber es kann sein, Best Bird steht natürlich auf der Liste, Okay Bird finde ich auch gut. Ich bin für Best Bird Fischreiher diese Woche. Ist wöchentlich eigentlich oder monatlich? Ach so, Best Bird Fischreiher, monatlich würde ich sagen, und dann haben wir noch einen Okay BirdBird, halt so ein Mittelmaß, Mediocre-Bird.
Und dann kam so ein Windstoss und der hat halt diese eine schöne Strähne hinten.
Oh, cool.
Die sind halt so ganz anmutige, grosse Tiere
und die haben halt so eine, so eine ganz schicke Frisur haben die.
Da habe ich mir auch überlegt, einfach nachzumachen.
Da habe ich noch nicht so gesehen.
Hinten einfach so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, siehst du wie so ein Zopf,
es ist eher so, die haben nur diese Haare.
Und dann weht der so im Wind.
Federn, glaube ich, meinst du, oder? Falala, falala, weht der dann so schön im Wind und das war so ganz anmutig, wie er auf dem Dach stand. Den kann ich jetzt immer beobachten. Aber das wäre doch auch mal gut, oder? Du gehst zum Friseur und sagst, welche Friseur hätten sie gerne? Ich habe ein Bild mitgebracht. Und dann zeigst du ein Bild von einem Kolibri einfach und man denkt, was, okay. Okay. Oh, das finde ich super gut. Ah, das ist doch eine geile Sketch-Reihe, oder? Oder eine Prank-Reihe, ja. Ehrlich gesagt, versteckte Kamera hat immer so einen faden Beigeschmack, aber richtig gemachte versteckte Kamerawitze, die lustig sind. Oh mein Gott, kann ich darüber lachen. Ja, vor allem, ich lache mich weg und das finde ich zum Beispiel sehr lustig. Einmal mal einen Vogel zeigen oder so einen Otter. Einen Vogel zeigen, guck mal, das ist doch schon mal die perfekte Rubrik. So heißt er auch die ganze Rubrik, die ganze Reihe. Und du überlegst, was, oder du hast so zehn Bilder mit aufsteigender Absurdität und du guckst und der Promi muss raten, bei welchem Bild fragt der Friseur nochmal nach. Also erstes Bild Nelly Furtado, so, kein Problem. Das ist mit Diologis heute. Zweites Bild Lisa Simpson oder so, wo du denkst, okay, ich sehe die Frisur. Und dann irgendwie achtes Bild Toaster, obwohl man wirklich überhaupt keine Ahnung mehr hat. Naja, die beiden Rillen. Toste ich glaube ich noch.
Und dann bilden neun so einen Kohlenstoffatom oder irgendwie so wirklich ultra strange. Und dann einfach gucken, man geht zum Friseur und du hast zehn Test-Test-Vögel und jeder geht rein und die Frage ist, ab welchem Punkt fragt der Friseur. Können Sie mir das vielleicht nochmal in anderen Wochen sagen? Lockvogel ist auch übrigens ein guter Titel. Es ist eine vogelthematische Sendung, in der kein einziger echter Vogel vorkommt, sondern nur Lockvögel. It's a worse bird production. It's a worse bird production. Sehr schön, eigentlich eine gute Idee. Finde ich nicht so schlecht, aber das mag ich sehr gern. Wir müssen mal wieder. Wir müssen Konzepte sammeln, ja. Wir müssen mal wieder mit Tele5. Ja, wir brauchen mal wieder einen Conference Call. Wir machen mal wieder einen Call. Machen wir ja einen schönen Tele5 Call. Wir pitchen, wie viele Bilder, bei welchem Bild, ja, am Tele5 müssen wir noch arbeiten. Ich sehe mich schon auch beim Skype Call dann, Stefan, was war deine Idee dazu, wenn ich sage, ach so, mal ... Und hinten der Vogel im Käfig. Und ich ruf so, ich ruf so, freeze. Und dann bleibt er auch so stehen. Und dann hast du noch so einen Effekt, wo so ein Kreis auf dein Gesicht zuzieht. Woher hat er das? Nee, es kommt sofort dieser Larry David Abspann. Der Curb Abspann. Alter, wie geil wäre das, wenn man bei Skype auf den Knopf drücken könnte und es kommt Rhythmia. Oder halt Dick Wolf. All die, ähm, wie heißt das? L.A. Confidential. Special Victims, SVU, Special Victims Unit. Ja, und auf jeden Fall, aber es ist eine gute Idee. Ja, finde ich sehr gut, machen wir. Spaß bei Friseuren, glaube ich, ist eh immer eine gute Idee. Apropos Spaß, man denkt immer so, oh geil, spaßige Zeiten, was leben wir, wir leben in einer Unterhaltungsgesellschaft. Spaßige Zeiten, schwieriges Thema. Na, gerade jetzt, alle sind auf Unterhaltung angewiesen, man sagt immer, oh was machst du da, eine Band, mein Gott, sucht den richtigen Job. Jetzt sind alle darauf angewiesen, dass es Leute gibt, die mal schönen Bass in die Hand nehmen und dann mal abreiben.
Und deswegen, wir leben in einer Unterhaltungsgesellschaft überall nur fanfan gute Laune und wir denken uns, mein Gott, früher war die Zeit so trist und leer und schwarz-weiß und immer nur Krieg und Pest und Mittler hier, Hitler da.
Ja, Mittelalter, Schwert, Hilfe, ich bin Bauer, ich kann nichts machen, ich kriege meinen Acker nicht beackert. Aber das muss gar nicht unbedingt sein, denn auch in früheren Zeiten gab es Fun, Fun, Fun, Comedy, Comedy, Pur. Was machst du jetzt? Jetzt kommt unsere neue Rubrik. Nein. Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch. Unsere neue Rubrik Humor History. Und wir haben nämlich mal vor langer, langer Zeit darüber gesprochen, ob es nicht Stand-up oder generell Comedy in der Antike und im Mittelalter gab, wie das denn aussah. Und wir konnten uns einfach keinen Reim machen, ob man da auch Gags gemacht hat oder wie das war, ob man die heute noch verstehen würde. Also übersetzt sich, heute kannst du noch irgendwie Oedipus als Theaterstück angucken oder Shakespeare, aber kann man auch Gags aus der Zeit sich noch geben zum Abschmunzeln? Ist da überhaupt was möglich? Und wir haben eine fantastische Einsendung bekommen. Man merkt immer an der Länge der Anmoderation, dass Florentin immer noch nach der Mail sucht. Und dann hat er Tipp, hört mal die Folgen jetzt nochmal an, so, und dann hört er immer, wenn die Anmoderation lang ist, fällt ihm ein, inmitten der Anmoderation, ach fuck, ich muss die Mail noch suchen, und dann holt er nochmal aus. Und zwar haben wir eine Mail bekommen von einem Hörer, und zwar von Wie heisst er?
Von Philogelos. Philogelos ist ein Comedian aus dem Jahre 248 nach Christus. Also schon sehr alt. Und ja, das ist tatsächlich eine Witzesammlung aus der Antike, ist auch im Riecklamverlag erschienen, also einige seiner Werke gibt es auch tatsächlich zu sehen und Philogelos hat für uns einen kleinen Ausschnitt aus seinem Stand-up-Programm aufgeschrieben.
Also wie ist es für euch, meine Damen und Herren, Philogelos!
Ja, vielen Dank, ich bin Stand-up-Komedien aus der Antike, ich bin der Philogelos und ich lese heute ein bisschen was aus meiner Witze-Sammlung vor.
Gut, ein grießgrämiger, einäuliger Arzt, der fragte einen Kranken, wie geht's, und der erwiderte, wie du siehst, worauf der Arzt sagte, wenn's dir so geht, wie ich sehe, da bist du halbtot. Gut, ich merke schon, Arztwitze stossen bei dem Publikum auf Lacher. Da ging zu einem übel gelaunen Arzt jemand und sagte, Meister, ich kann weder liegen noch stehen und auch nicht sitzen. Worauf der Arzt ihm entgegnete, dann bleibt dir nichts anderes übrig, als dich aufzuhängen. Ein Mann mit stinkendem Atem, der begegnete einem Arzt. Sieh her, sagte er, mein Zäpfchen hat sich gesenkt", und er machte seinen Mund weit auf. Der Arzt erwandte sich ab und sagte, ,,nicht dein Zäpfchen hat sich gesenkt, sondern ein Arschloch hat sich gehoben". Eine unerwartete Antwort bekam jemand, ein Frauenhasser, der bestattete seine Frau. Als jemand fragte, ,,wer hatitten, antwortete er, ich, der Witwer. Vielen Dank, vielen Dank, Filogelos, Witzesammlung, danke, danke, danke. Danke, Filogelos, danke schön. Wow, vielen, vielen Dank. Handgeklapper für diese Einsendung. Krass, vor allem das ist ja Witze. Es sind klassische Humoreske. Kommt man beim Arzt Witze. Obwohl, gibt's jetzt mal du als Comedy-Connoisseur, du verpönst ja, also ich höre da eine kleine Abwertung in dieser Einschätzung. Gibt's aber auch wirkliche Witze, die du gut findest? Oder kannst du da wirklich nur drüber ironisch lächeln? Ich war in einem Interview-Podcast eingeladen, hätte ich mir vorher mal anhören sollen, dass der immer endet mit und jetzt erzählt er mit den Witz. Und mir ist kein Witz eingefallen, einfach, mir ist kein Witz eingefallen. Ich kenne keinen Witz, keinen Witz, ich kann mir keinen Witz merken von diesen Dingern, weil ich die so belanglos finde und sofort abstemple als ja weg. Ich höre auch meistens nicht zu, weil ich nur darauf warte, weil ich es unangenehm finde, dieses also sind zwei dann schon zuzuhören, diese drei Struktur, und dann höre ich schon gar nicht zu, was immer dazu führt, dass ich krampfhaft die Gesichter lese, um herauszufinden, wann ich jetzt lachen muss. Genau, ich versuche auch immer mehr zu gucken, wo ist der Punkt, an dem ich lachen soll, und ich gucke mal, habe ich ihn verpasst, war das der Moment? Und man muss ja, man kann ja während man dem Witz zuhört, wo noch nichts Lustiges passiert während der Feedline, muss man aber trotzdem schon so belustig gucken.
Das ist die schlimmste Zeit.
Man kann nicht einfach nur ernst schauen,
weil man muss schon so
oder auch nicht zu angestrengt.
Du darfst nicht zu
zu skeptisch oder zu
schwer zu beschreiben, wie du schaust.
In ablehnender Erwartung.
Ablehnend, was passiert hier,
in welche Richtung geht das?
Ja, skeptisch, skeptisch. Maximale Auflösung, auch. Ja, ja. Das ist ein bisschen in diesem erwartenden Lachen. Ja, ja. Ja, aber ich bin ja gar nicht so Arzt. Ja, Arzt. Aber genau, das ist ganz, ganz schwierig hier, deswegen, ich mag tatsächlich keinen von diesen Witz. Nee, finde ich auch immer eine ganz unangenehme Situation. Es gibt einen Witz, den mag ich sehr gerne, den kann ich hier nicht erzählen, weil er sehr körperlich ist.
Tatsächlich, aber
den mag ich sehr gerne, das ist glaube ich der einzige
Witz, wo ich wirklich hart gelacht habe
von einem meiner Mitschüler,
der extrem lustig war in der Schule.
Hat der den erfunden oder auch wiedererzählt?
Weiss man nicht genau, aber der meinte
mal, das sei sein Lieblingswitz und das ist ja
der traurigste Moment, also für mich
zumindest, jetzt haben natürlich andere Menschen andere
Kriterien an Menschen als ich, aber
Vielen Dank. Weiss man nicht genau, weiss man nicht genau, aber der meinte mal, das sei sein Lieblingswitz und das ist ja der traurigste Moment, also für mich zumindest, jetzt haben natürlich andere Menschen andere Kriterien an Menschen als ich, aber wenn man wirklich so, wo man denkt, der war so fucking lustig in der Schule, der war so lustig, mit dem konnte man immer scheiße reden und dann macht man Abi und verliert sich und so ein paar Jahre später trifft man sich wieder und du merkst, dieser Mensch ist ganz anders.. Jedes Körnchen Humor wurde dem irgendwie ausgetrieben.
Vom Leben ausgetrieben.
Ja, als hätte er so Desinfektionsmittel getrunken und alles verbrannt, was mit Humor zu tun hat.
Was ist das Humor Desinfektionsmittel?
Keine Ahnung. Erwachsen werden, das ernste Leben zu führen, zu ernstem Job, ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung.
Aber das ist wirklich so und du denkst, man ist ja noch in diesem Modus, dieses, ja, ja, so, und beim anderen einfach so gar nichts und du denkst, das kann nicht sein.
Oh mein Gott. Wirklich so, als wäre der ins Koma gefallen und anders aufgewachsen. Und für mich ist es immer so traurig, die zu sehen. Und der hat dann irgendwie einen Job und irgendwie Verlobte und die wollen bald heiraten und zahlen jetzt ein Haus an und so und denkst dir, alles toll, aber du hast alles verloren. Du hast alles verloren, bei dem Weg, das alles so ... Ja, natürlich. Der Humor als extrem wichtige Eigenschaft wahrnimmt. Absolut. Und er hat wahrscheinlich den Fokus anders gesetzt. Ich sag dir auch nicht, dass ich Leute nicht melden kann, die nicht lustig sind, nur diese krasse Veränderung zu beobachten. Es ist irgendwie, bricht das Herz so ein bisschen. Ja, bei mir war es auch so, ich habe einen Kumpel gehabt, den ich für den lustigsten Menschen der Welt gehalten habe in der Schule und der dann losging, um Physik zu studieren, wo ich genau wusste, wo ich genau diese Änderungen antizipiert hatte, der aber jetzt immer noch wahnsinnig lustig ist, muss man sagen. Er ist lustiger als ich und erfolgreicher als ich und hat einen Physik-Master. Aber gut, also unsympathisch auf eine Art auch. Ist ja auch nicht lustig, wenn man so perfekt ist, ne? Ja. So, können wir ... So, wir haben ... Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir noch was zu sagen können zu der Supernova, die letzte Woche angekündigt hast, aus der nichts geworden ist, hat nicht stattgefunden. Nee, aber jetzt die nächste Woche könnte es stattfinden. Wie viele Folgen lang sagst du jetzt? Die nächste Woche? Nee, nächste Woche. Ja, diese Woche oder nächste Woche? Ich bin mir sicher, dass kommende Woche habe ich das im Gefühl, dass B-Tag-Deutsche ... Das ist KW 18, ne? KW 18, nee, 14, nee, 14. Das ist leider die schlimmste Erfindung der Welt. Wirklich. Können wir uns einfach, was ist denn gegen Daten anzuwenden überhaupt? Ja, ja. Die Woche vom 1. April zum Beispiel. Nee, dann treffen wir uns einfach KW-18 nochmal und du einfach. Wo, wann? Ja, ich komm nicht. Keine Ahnungche vom keine ahnung man muss ja nicht mal daten sind viel besser also da ist ja nicht ohne grund hat man sich dagegen kbs entschieden ja das ist so wie dieses komische system es ist auch eine andere lebensrealität auch so quartale immer wenn es heißt drittes quartal muss ich immer denken januar februar märz april ich gehe mit die höcker die höcker lang vom fingerknöchel ja Ja gut, bei meiner Fetthand ist die Hälfte der Knöchel schon verschwunden. Aber wie genial sind eigentlich diese Höcker? Ohne Scheiss. Januar, Februar, März, April, Mai, Juni, Juli, August. Juli und August haben beide 31 Tage und beide haben Höcker, Knöchel, Knöchelhöcker. Wie hat man das ausgefunden? Wer kommt darauf? Das ist wirklich genial. Vor allem das ist ja was, das könnte genauso gut einfach nicht existieren, dieser Merkspruch mit den Knöcheln. Ja. Also das ist ja kein, du denkst dir so, oh wow, toll, der Mensch, der den Strom entdeckt hat, wo man sich denkt, naja, der wäre halt vielleicht hundert Jahre später entdeckt worden, aber man hätte darauf gekommen, weil es gibt Blitze. Oder hätte man einen Monat geändert. Hätte man dann gesagt, nee, oder wurden die Monate an die Knöchel angepasst? Ja, das stimmt schon. Das ist meine Frage. Dann geht man zum Kaiser und sagt, Kaiser, ich habe eine geile Idee. Also, wenn wir jetzt den Eintrag vom August zum September legen, dann würde das genau passen. Ich glaube, supergeil. Das war eh eine coole Zeit. Ich habe letztens gelesen, dass der Bayern, schreibt man hier mit Y, aber nicht immer. Früher hat man das mit I geschrieben, B-A-I. Und irgendwann wurde das geändert, einfach weil der König gesagt hat, ich bin großer Fan von Griechenland, der antiken Griechen. Deswegen haben wir jetzt einfach ein Y in den Namen unseres Landes ein. Wirklich? Ja, einfach gesagt, geil, oder? Y, Bayern, Y. Ja, ist okay.
Ist doch ganz geil.
Ja, ist auch Bayern immer noch.
Ja, eben, aber es ist halt Y,
so ein kleiner Hutzieher.
Wenn man sagt Bayern, dann sagen
Leute, schreiben Sie mal mit I,
dann muss man das Buchstabieren.
Ja, aber wir haben jetzt diese
neuen Druckmaschinen gekauft und die A's sind komplett abgewetzt, die B's sind komplett durch, die E's kann man kaum noch lesen, Y, messerscharf, perfekte Drucksiegel. Kein Mann benutzt die Y's. Lass uns doch jetzt mal alle, nee, gute Idee, lass uns mal alle Wörter, wo ein I ist, jetzt einfach mal durch ein, nee, nicht nicht ... Wieso, I hat Unbewandtnis.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Genau wie damals Carmen mit C geschrieben wurde, meine Heimatstadt.
Bis man gesagt hat, Cs müssen wir klein halten.
Cs wollen zu viel.
My Lord, die Cs werden zu viel.
Köln war auch C.
Irgendwann hat man gesagt, Colonia. Viva Colonia, ist das C noch da? Da ist es noch da. Ode Kolonia. Ja. Ist auch noch drin. Man merkt, das C war omnipräsent im Mittelalter. Und da hat jemand gesagt, nee, komm, jetzt machen wir mal am Anfang des Wortes fahren wir das C mal runter. Wir fahren es mal ein bisschen runter. Diese Meetings, ich wäre so gern bei solchen Meetings dabei, weil die muss es ja in der Geschichte immer wieder gegeben haben. Gibt es die denn heute noch? Wahrscheinlich schon so neue Feiertage und so, oder irgendwie müssen wir so, wer entscheidet das, so ein Ausschuss? Die Politik, wahrscheinlich hat da kein Abgeordneter Bock drauf. Ich glaube doch. Komitee für neue Feiertage. Ich glaube, weil die machen wahnsinnig viel Arbeit, aber so eine Scheinarbeit. Man kann dann sagen, ich hätte noch dieses Bayern-mit-y-Schreib-Projekt. Und alle sagen, okay, kannst du uns helfen mit diesem neuen Ausschuss? Und dann kannst du immer sagen, nee, sorry, ich habe noch gerade dieses ... Das ist schon verrückt, du wirst Politiker und dann ist es vielleicht nur eine Entscheidung deines Lebens, der macht den Unterschied zwischen, bist du Verteidigungsminister und entscheidest, wie viele fucking Panzer wir haben, oder sitzt du im irgendwie Heimatkunde was und entscheidest, ob irgendwas Urkundenschutz, nee, ob irgendwie so ein Baudenkmal geschützt wird oder nicht, was niemanden interessiert. Und es ist einfach nur eine Entscheidung. Denkmalschutz, genau, was unter Denkmalschutz gesetzt wird und was nicht. Oder wem jetzt eine neue Statue gebaut wird und du sagst, es interessiert niemanden. Das ist genau ein bisschen, also nichts gegen, ich denke auch immer bei Polizisten so, die Verkehrspolizisten sind einfach die uncoolen Polizisten. Nichts gegen Verkehrspolizisten, absolut wichtige Arbeit. Du bist eher für Fahrradpolizisten? Naja, aber man denkt sich halt so, klar, du bist irgendwie in der Mordkommissionsabteilung, irgendwie lass uns den Gangster hochnehmen oder so, oder hier Drogenhandel und die verstecken sich im Busch, und denkst du, cool. Der andere ist halt dann einfach so, ja, wer ist wem hinten drauf gefahren, aha, okay, hier, sorry, hier, fahrt mal rechts. Du kannst aber die Kreide, kannst du so Sachen aufmalen. Das machen andere, das machen so, das machen andere.
Das habe ich mal beobachtet, da gab es einen Unfall,
weil da war ich auf dem Balkon, wir haben gegrillt
auf dem Balkon und dann war halt direkt
vor dem Balkon halt so eine
Kreuzung und da war halt ein richtig heftiger
Motorradunfall, wo der
Motorradfahrer auch gestorben ist im Krankenhaus.
Und wir saßen halt und haben das halt einfach
gesehen und du rennst
jetzt ja nicht runter und hilfst oder so,
da kam ein Krankenwagen und so
und so, dann ist halt,
Man kann es nicht mehr so gut machen da kam ein Krankenwagen und so. Und so, dann ist halt, man guckt halt dann zu. Der Grill ist halt schon an. Weil man ist halt jetzt, weil man fühlt sich nicht als Gaffer, weil man sitzt ja da, wo man davor auch schon saß. Es ist halt nur vor einem passiert. Und dann kamen dann auch irgendwann so ganz spezielle Polizisten. Aber weißt du, hat man mal besprochen, das Grillen zumindest nach innen zu verlegen oder? Aus Respekt? Ja. Du kannst doch nicht im Raum grillen. Nein, aber den Grill draußen köcheln. Was, Elektrogrill oder Holzkohlegrill? Oh, die Holzkohlegrill, Stefan. Okay, also dann kannst du nicht einfach ausmachen, dann ist der jetzt an. Der ist an und die Würstchen liegen jetzt erstmal drauf. Die WürstchenGürze. Kann man runternehmen, kann sagen, wir lassen uns mal erinnern. Ja, aber dann ne. Okay, gut, verstehe ich. Dann hat man überlegt, mal das Essen reinzuverlegen zumindest. Aber das ist ja auch unabhängig. Du musst ja werden essen halt gucken, wie die Würstchen sind. Da kann ja einer Würstchen-Schicht schieben. Ja, aber dann kann man sich nicht unterhalten, wenn einer auf dem Balkon ist und alle anderen drin. Kann man vielleicht mal einfach einsehen, dass es nicht mehr die beste Grillparty wird und dann von einem Topnotch-Grillstandard abrücken.
Nein, nein, wenn du nur zynisch genug bist, dann wird die Grillparty dadurch nur besser, weil es halt einfach eine weirde Situation ist. Und irgendwann kamen dann so Spezialisten, so Verkehrsspezialisten, die haben dann diesen Unfall rekonstruiert.
Die haben dann genau geguckt, weil das muss man anscheinend relativ schnell machen, weil da sind dann noch so Bremsspuren und so und dann sehen die genau, das Motorrad lag da.
Der ist irgendwie so vorne übergefallen irgendwie, der ist, der ist halt, musste scharf bremsen und dann ist der irgendwie vorne übergekippt und so.
Und dann haben die halt die ganze Straße geräumt und dann haben die genau mit so Linien geguckt, wie die Winkel sind und dann mit so Guckrohren und so.
Das waren aber keine normalen Polizisten, die hatten auch keine Uniform an und dann dachte ich mir so, dass dann halt, wie die Winkel sind und dann mit so Guckrohren und so. Das waren aber keine
normalen Polizisten, die hatten auch keine Uniform an. Und dann dachte ich mir so, dass dann halt so, die werden halt gewohnt. Wurde ich gefragt als Zeugen eigentlich mal? Gar nicht. Nee? Gar nicht. Nee, wir haben Würstchen angeboten, aber ansonsten nichts. Einfach so, sollen wir viel da Grillkäse runterwerfen und dann hier sind überall Fettspuren in den ganzen Dokumenten drin. War dir vielleicht schuld an dem Unfall?
Nein. Unser Geruch?
Nee, weil dir so Würstchen auf die Strasse geworfen habt. Wo kommt das ganze Öl her auf der Strasse? Ja, ja, weil du hast nicht so deine, diese Brennflüssigkeit ist ja ausgelaufen unten oder so. Ja, nee, aber wir wussten ja damals auch noch nicht, dass der sterben wird. Das haben wir dann später erst in der Zeitung gelesen, dass der im Krankenhaus dann gestorben ist. Zu dem Zeitpunkt, man kann ja schwer einschätzen, wie schwer so ein Unfall ist, aber das heißt, da waren wir noch angemessen zynisch. Angetrunken. Aber das ist dann spannend und ich habe nichts gegen Verkehrspolizisten, ich denke mir immer, so, es gibt innerhalb des gleichem Berufsstandes Kuhle. Wobei das ein schlechtes Beispiel war für eine sehr coole. Das sind immer die letzten zehn Minuten des Podcasts, wo ich mich immer um Kopf und Kragen rede, den eh keiner mehr hört, wo alle schon eingeschlafen sind. Oder man merkt, jetzt brauche ich schon langsam die Ausfahrt oder jetzt parke ich gerade ein und mache den Podcast aus, um besser einparken zu können. Das sind nur so die Momente. Ich mache ihn immer leiser ein bisschen. Ja? Müh leiser. Ja, ist okay. Ne, ich mache aus und dann das ganz peinliche Schweigen hinten in der Rückbank, wo sich nichts ändert, ob der Fahrer fährt oder einparkt, ändert sich für die Rückbank nichts. Ich finde es immer lustig, wenn man Leuten sagt, setz dich bitte hinten ins Auto. Ja. Und dann fährt man von alleine. Ja. Wir haben so ein Machtgefühl. Und Taxifahrergefühl. Wenn ich bei jemandem mitfahre, setze ich mich immer hinten. Immer nach hinten. Und dann ist es so ein Blick, aber auch kein so ein, setz dich doch vor, sondern so ein, gut, dann ist es jetzt so eine Chauffeursituation. Es ist automatisch eine, hat man einen Hochstatus, wenn man sich hinten hinsetzt. Absolut, mach das. Ja, aber es ist mega weird direkt für die Freundschaft. Wir sprechen uns nächste Woche wieder. Ja, bis dahin bitte alles drin, die Zentrale. Bleibt da zu Hause, entspannt euch, macht euch mal einen Tee oder sowas. Und über den Todeskometen reden wir nächste Woche noch, vielleicht kriegen wir Frebel an die Strippe und können das mal alles klären, wie es ist mit der Supernova.
Schaut, gen Bethegeuzi, ihr könnt es am Gürtel des Orion erkennen, am Gürtel des Orion sind drei Sterne in einer Reihe, die sind sehr hell auch, guckt da mal hin.
Macht's gut, wir haben's, ciao!
This podcast is brought to you by Worst Bird.